Gestalten wie aus einem Albtraum.
Einmal im Jahr werden sie losgelassen
im idyllischen Örtchen Heldra
im Norden des Bundeslandes Hessen.
Ein Dorf mit gerade mal 500 Einwohnern,
aber mit einer großen Tradition:
den Strohbären.
Und ich werde einer von ihnen sein.
Meine Herausforderung heute:
Ich lass mich nicht nur um den Finger,
sondern ganz einwickeln -
und zwar mit Stroh.
40 Kilo davon soll ich tragen.
In dieser Scheune kann ich mir schon mal
anschauen, was mich nachher erwartet.
Allerdings bin ich heute
als Letzter an der Reihe.
Zeit für eine kleine Recherche zur Geschichte
des Strohbären am Dorfmuseum.
Hallo, ich bin der Max.
Hallo, wie geht’s?
Hallo!
Tach!
Ich würd‘ gern mal ‘nen bisschen mehr
über den Ursprung des Strohbären erfahren.
Wie fing das denn alles an, diese Tradition?
Oh, das liegt im Dunkeln.
Also, wir kennen den Strohbär-Tag
seit unserer frühesten Jugend
und unsere Eltern kennen ihn auch
seit der frühesten Jugend.
Also, da ist kein Datum festgehalten.
Das hat bisher bedeutet und das bedeutet
immer noch das Winteraustreiben.
Zurück zur Scheune.
Die Menge des Strohs,
das vom Winter übrig blieb,
bestimmt,
wie viele Strohbären mitlaufen können.
In diesem Jahr reicht es für sechs.
Das Brechen des Strohs an den Gelenken
gehört dazu,
sonst könnten die Bären sich gar nicht
bewegen.
Wer fertig ist,
muss vor der Scheune warten.
Dass ich hier mitmachen darf,
ist eine Ausnahme.
Ob es auch eine gute Idee ist,
da bin ich mir nicht mehr so sicher.
Jetzt werde ich ins Stroh gewickelt.
Übrigens von echten Profis,
keiner hier macht das zum ersten Mal.
Bis zu zwei Stunden kann es dauern,
bis das ganze Stroh da sitzt, wo es hingehört.
Die meisten der Wickler
waren selbst schon mal ein Strohbär.
Mitleid haben sie jedoch nicht.
Sie zurren und zerren erbarmungslos an mir.
Wo bin ich hier?
Am, am Oberschenkel.
Oder … also hinten am Oberschenkel.
Wie weit vom Arsch weg?
Äh.. ja, geht noch ‘n bisschen.
Das gibt's ja gar nicht hier.
Der Wickelprozess ist für denjenigen,
der drin steckt, gar nicht so ungefährlich.
Arme und Beine können einschlafen,
wenn zu fest gewickelt wurde.
Und nicht wenige sind auch schon mal
in Ohnmacht gefallen.
Auch deshalb wird das Stroh
an den Gelenken gebrochen.
Und so zwingt mich
diese uralte Tradition in die Knie.
Ich soll mehr Bewegungsfreiheit gewinnen,
verliere aber dabei fast die Balance.
Richtig rüber. Genau. Hoch.
Ja – und hoch.
So, jetzt gerade die Füße
und nicht mit den Knien laufen.
Mein erster Gang …
Ein Taxi für die Bären gibt es nicht.
Wie richtige Strohballen werden sie mit dem
Traktor Richtung Startpunkt gekarrt.
Selten hab' ich mich so ausgeliefert gefühlt.
Aber es gibt Licht am Horizont:
Jemand wird sich in den nächsten Stunden
um mich kümmern.
Ich führ‘ dich heute durch diesen Tag,
als Bärenführerin.
Wenn was ist,
einfach Bescheid sagen.
Ich vertrau‘ dir voll und ganz.
Muss ich auch,
ich hab‘ keine andere Wahl.
Denn auch das gehört zur Tradition:
Jeder Mann im Stroh
bekommt eine Bärenführerin,
die ihn an einer Kette durchs Dorf leitet.
Im Stroh stecken
ohne Ausnahme nur junge Männer,
keiner älter als Ende 20,
denn die halten die Strapazen am besten aus.
Jeder schleppt jetzt circa 40 Kilo
mit sich herum.
Uns Strohbären bleibt tatsächlich
nichts erspart.
Ich habe gerade erst in meiner Verkleidung
laufen gelernt, da soll ich tanzen.
In grauer Vorzeit mal die Gelegenheit
für die Dorfjugend,
sich näherzukommen -
mit Sicherheitsabstand aus Stroh.
Nach zwei sehr langen Stunden gibt es den
Endspurt, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes.
Alle Strohbären rennen los.
Ich kann es kaum noch aushalten,
und den anderen geht es nicht anders.
Die Strohbären enden als wilder Haufen.
Aber endlich werden wir befreit
und aus dem Stroh geschnitten.
Was für eine Tortur!
Strohreste sitzen noch überall.
Juhuuu!
Dass sich die Strapazen lohnen,
auch das spüre ich jetzt ganz hautnah.
Der Tag endet mit einem großen Feuer.
All das Stroh, das stundenlang gewickelt
und von uns getragen wurde,
geht in wenigen Minuten in Rauch auf.
Ja, so warm war mir ungefähr
im Kostüm auch selbst.
Aber was ich gelernt habe,
es war ein wirklich schöner Tag,
eine echt schöne Tradition,
die das ganze Dorf,
die ganze Gemeinde zusammengebracht hat.
Und für einen Tag war ich auch Teil
von der Gemeinde hier in Heldra.
Einer der anstrengendsten Tage
meines Reporterlebens geht zu Ende.
In die Haut der Strohbären werde ich mich
wohl nicht noch einmal wickeln lassen.